can I ask one question really quick
because I I know that you guys do get
this one criticism occasionally that
sometimes on the anime podcast if
there's no we don't talk about anime
right sometimes it's not a criticism not
at all I love it I I've enjoyed it I
just wanted to I I'm curious how I know
how anime started in America but I want
to know how you what was your guys's
like first exposure to animix I'm sure
you've told it before but I just haven't
heard it personally and I want to see
how that compares with like
1997-98 and the the horrors of what you
would have had to go through by liking
anime when it started although I mean
like I would say because I've heard
stories about people who got it into
anime and like your era way it's kind of
like your era your era
I can finally say that because normally
everyone I I look at like other content
creators and I'm just like you don't
know the pain
for me it was like it was part one out
of three espanol subtitle on YouTube
yeah on YouTube on YouTube yeah people
would like upload rips it would upload
because back then they had a 10 minute
uh like a 10 minute limit so that they
would upload parts of the anime into
threes because it was obviously 24
minutes yeah really yeah yeah and you
can get a whole anime series just upload
it on YouTube unless unless it was like
you find part one but you can't find
yeah but there's part three yeah yeah
yeah that would happen a lot yeah you'd
have to just kind of be like I just want
to get through this anime so I'm going
to skip half of this episode and then
that's a crucial detail yeah that's so
crazy I mean yeah a lot of people my age
they go into anime through like tsunami
and yeah Adult Swim that was like a like
Dragon Ball Z Gundam Wing uh try Gun
Cowboy
huge push yeah like in in terms of like
exposing people to anime and then the
internet era came on
um and that's when people started
discovering shows like Naruto and bleach
and one piece and that got a whole load
of other people influence around me as
well who discovered anime through the
internet basically and but you paid the
social price back on the day when you
had to go to the video store or
something like that or Toonami what do
you mean this uh the social price like
when it was [__] anime liking anime
yeah like oh no I was a close-up anime
fan uh yeah yeah I I you know America
like you mentioned Toonami was the big
one that so like 98 99 2000 yeah and I
remember they showed some of Dragon Ball
Z I remember my friends ordered tapes
like VHS they paid like we saved up all
of our money and I was like I'm not
gonna contribute because I think this
shit's too dorky still but I I want to
support you guys I'll pay like the
postage and they got like they ordered
it from Japan and it was like 28 29
different VHS tapes whatever and the
worst quality like you could not eat and
there was no subtitles yeah we were just
watching the cartoons and I was like
you're watching the pixels I was like
this is lame and I remember I was like
nah I'm go I'm gonna pivot here I'm not
doing the Dragon Ball thing I went to a
family video we had in Kansas City and
they had like
the anime section was kind of off by
itself as it was and I was like no this
looks cool and I mentioned on a video I
did with you uh ninja scroll was the
first thing that I'd seen that came out
like 93 right ninja scroll is [__]
cool it's [__] awesome so I was like
wow this is amazing so then I got into
like record of lodos for Neon Genesis
yeah and I remember the dude was like
the guy working there was like hey man I
know you've been like checking out a lot
of the anime stuff you get like two
video games and like one anime I got
something to like blow your mind dude
and I was like let's [__] go he was
like all right normally like someone
your age can't actually go over there so
I'll just sneak it into like your bag
dude and I was like let's go and then uh
now this was unfortunate because when I
thought we were gonna watch something
kind of like I don't know like Vampire
Hunter D or whatever yeah yeah yeah uh
and my mom was like what are you
watching I like cartoons and I was like
yeah check it out this [__] was called
like shin Angel and it was like hardcore
hentai and I'm in my mind
I'm ashamed to say that I know Shane you
know actually that [__] started with
like pornography it like starts with
some vivid dream he's having and I was
like I think this is just the previous
job I was like this shit's weird the
whole time she was like oh dear this
isn't Disney and I was like no I was
like this is just some weird I don't
know what they do over you know I don't
know what's going on but like the the
regular one the guy promised me it's
cool and she was like okay and I was
like but you don't have to watch you can
leave now and then it starts with Like A
Slice of Life School thing yeah and then
it's like this dude trying to like with
the subtitles or no if it was okay and
so I this one had something
this one was the VHS from the store the
ones we ordered were from a guy
recording
like International we waited like two
months during the summer to get a box of
tapes that also had like different
Japanese programs and commercials right
right yeah but Shin Angel didn't have
any of that and that was like and so we
made it about four minutes through that
thing and I hey silly I turned it off
and she was like I think he gave you the
wrong one and I was like yes he did that
guy is in big trouble you
go away and I'm gonna make sure this
tape goes right back to him right
tomorrow morning and then I hid that
tape in my couch for like two years I
was like I'm never giving that back
because I don't wanna I was like one
it's kind of cool but two I don't want
to be the guy to be bringing back Shin
Angel to it Family Video
with my my anime I was like
that's enough I'm going back to games
this is what we do was it like so like
how popular was anime like at your era
was it like looked down upon with people
like bullying looked down upon it was
the single worst thing you could do to
your social standing good I just want I
just wanted to confirm D and D nerds
were like dude that is too much
you remind me like a story though I I
had like in University so we were having
like a boys line University
um
we're at the pub we had a few drinks and
we had like you know kind of like a boys
chat and uh the question got uh someone
posed the question what's what's the
most thing you've been ashamed about
jacking off to everyone's like silent
for a bit and then one of my mate just
goes oh I jacked off to anime porn once
and everyone went oh [__] you actually
did that and here's me like silently
sipping on a plane being like
I'm not gonna say anything man you're
not gonna say anything
today yeah oh that's that's disgusting
man you you did that well the line was
blurred back then because uh anime and
nudity went hand in hand right because
there was some cool [__] that I remember
reading like gunsmith cats do you guys
know this yeah yeah like that was like a
cool thing to read Because or you know
the stories were really interesting yeah
but it always towed the line of decency
compared to like what everyone else was
into true and it wasn't really until you
Japan became kind of cool again like
around Battle Royale you know when that
started pushing things off in video
games but like anime not even until
College was that [__] allowed like you
if you liked anime you're also complicit
with liking hentai yeah well I mean
especially because like during like the
like especially like around the time
when you were getting in so like around
the world and I never got into it I want
to make that clearer
you know like around like the ninja
scroll era like the early 90s like that
was when like the 90s OVA boom was
around yeah that was during the time
where the anime industry was like No
Holds bar like nothing was off limits so
like you always had these shows that
were just like okay yeah it's just a
simple story of kids going to school
that's a lot of tits yeah and it's like
and there was no sign of that [__]
either and it just came like out of
nowhere well it was totally rampant
because there was some really cool anime
like even like Street Fighter 2 or the
King of Fighters or fatal Fury animes
yeah like those are really cool like
they were just these One-Shot kind of
like two-hour things but you still have
like Chun-Li taking a shower and like
that would never fly on like a Capcom
franchise today they'd you know I was
like it's such a weird like you had to
either hide it or or you know be that
guy it was like yes I like anime and
everyone's like dork and then you're
just like that's cool man you wouldn't
nerd that the Nerds would make fun of
yeah you would be it's a tough one but I
do think it's neat because now I have
seen it come full circle like now it's
like you don't like anime you're a
little kids have it so [__] easy
today yeah man but I can't believe for
not liking it it's not fair man like you
don't like Demon Slayer okay or it's
like or it's kind of like a thing where
it's like you've only watched Naruto you
[__] know me like it's like bro well
there you have it I guess I'm glad I
dodged that particular bullet because I
was in the I was all in on gaming that
was all like that was all I cared about
and stuff but yeah that was it was a
death nail in Social and imagine talking
to any kind of dating opportunity zero
percent
you remind me of a ninja from the forest
the way you stealthily move through math
class
um I almost went further with that joke
and then I stopped but like that was the
it was it was too much it was just too
much